un tribunal de osaka decretó que la
prohibición del matrimonio entre
personas del mismo sexo en japón es
constitucional en 2019 parejas del mismo
sexo iniciaron una demanda contra el
gobierno y exigieron un millón de yenes
por pareja por daños y perjuicios esto
para compensar la discriminación que
sufren la sentencia fue recibida con
gran decepción fuera del tribunal aunque
creo que es una sentencia terrible han
dictaminado que es constitucional que se
discrimine a las personas por su
sexualidad que no pueden cambiar
estoy extremadamente furiosa y muy
decepcionada
según las leyes actuales las parejas del
mismo sexo no pueden heredar los bienes
del otro ni tienen derechos parentales
sobre sus hijos los demandantes
argumentaron que se les había privado de
los mismos beneficios económicos y
legales de los que gozan las parejas
heterosexuales a través del matrimonio
la sentencia del lunes entra en
conflicto con otra dictada por un
tribunal de sapporo el año pasado que
declaró inconstitucional la prohibición
el apoyo a la diversidad sexual ha
crecido lentamente en japón pero aún
faltan protecciones legales para la
comunidad lgbt
creo que los japoneses tienen hoy en día
más intereses en los asuntos el gp y qu
pero en comparación con el extranjero
creo que el país todavía no se siente
cómodo para que esas personas vivan aquí
qué tal personalmente espero que esto
cambie
el tribunal se instó al parlamento a
buscar métodos para proteger mejor las
relaciones entre personas del mismo sexo
incluyendo opciones para legalizar el
matrimonio entre estas personas los
demandantes y sus abogados dijeron que
apelarían